c'est un procès hors normes qui s'est
déroulé à londres cette semaine
lundi la justice britannique s'est
penché sur la demande d'extradition de
julian assange vers les états unis
accusés de piratage informatique par
washington le fondateur de wikileaks
risque jusqu'à 175 ans de prison en
vertu des lois américaines anti
espionnage au coeur de ce procès
médiatique les juges devront déterminer
si la demande d'extradition et
disproportionnées ou incompatible avec
les droits de l'homme
du côté des proches d'assange en cas
d'extradition elle sera selon eux avant
tout motivée par des raisons politiques
l'oppression des journalistes la
malveillance constante des autorités à
l'égard de julian les dix ans de
détention arbitraire dont les nations
unies sont témoins c'est ce qui attend
les journalistes les éditeurs et tous
ceux qui produisent du contenu
si cette extradition cette extradition
politique de julian assange se
concrétise
les juges devront également tranché
concernant les motivations du
cyber-militant australien du côté de
wikileaks le constat est sans appel le
contexte c'est une super puissance
agressive qui veut rendre les coups et
qui cherche à se venger sur le plan
politique ils veulent faire de julian
assange un exemple ils veulent t frayer
les autres journalistes qu'ils aient
peur de faire leur travail sur tous ceux
qui s'intéressent aux questions de
sécurité le procès auquel nous assistons
ici n'est compréhensible que si on prend
en compte la présence de puissance
néfastes qui tentent justement
d'étouffer de faire taire leurs actions
malveillantes
mercredi le lanceur d' alerte s'est
plaint de ne pas avoir des échanges
assez privé avec ses avocats
julian assange est apparu très affaibli
ses avocats ont évoqué les traitements
inhumains et d
radan que pourrait subir leur client en
cas d'extradition aux états unis
jeudi la justice britannique est
suspendu jusqu'au 18 mai l'examen de la
demande d'extradition de julian assange
les auditions reprendront à partir de
cette date pour trois semaines
le verdict devrait être rendu avant
l'été
[Musique]